Dann herzlich willkommen zur Alternativlos-Folge Nr. 4.
Dem Boulevard-Podcast von Fefe und Frank.
Und wir fangen wie üblich mal an mit den Hausmeisterthemen. eines der wichtigsten Hausmeisterthemen, was wir jetzt so hatten in den letzten Tagen, war die Audioqualität dieses Podcasts, wo wir doch einige beschwerden bekommen haben, weil wir letztes Mal in einer sehr schön hallenden Umgebung waren, die war nämlich das Foyer der Berliner Kunst-Universität, der Künste und dort haben wir aufgenommen. Das fand leider nicht die Gnade unserer Zuhörer, einige fanden es halt zu doll, deswegen sind wir jetzt mal wieder an einem nicht näher genannten, etwas ruhigeren Ort und hoffen, dass wir die nächste Folge dann tatsächlich mit, dank euren Schletterspenden gekauften, besseren Audioequipment bestreiten können.
Das hätte eigentlich heute in der Mail sein sollen, aber es gab da Verzögerungen.
Genau.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, wir können nicht länger warten, wir müssen heute aufnehmen.
Ja, es war leider Alternativlos, dass wir heute aufnehmen mussten. Die Schuld trägt natürlich ein großer gelber Logistikkonzern aus Deutschland, der nicht in der Lage war, zeitgemäß zu liefern. Oder so ähnlich. Also, damit wird die Schuldfrage, wie immer, geklärt. Also, wenn heute noch irgendwelche beschwerden an Audio sind, ist diesmal die deutsche Post. nächstes Mal dann hoffentlich besser mit professionellen Headsetts. Ansonsten noch mal der Hinweis, wir haben zum Ende des jahres ja wieder den cross-communication-congress und da gibt es einen Call for Participation, der ist raus, schon seit einer Weile. Die Deadline für die Einreichung von Vorträgen nähert sich so langsam mit großen Schritten, die war irgendwann Anfang Mitte Oktober. Und demzufolge solltet ihr vielleicht zusehen, dass ihr möglichst bald euren Vortrag dort einrecht, um sicher zu sein, dass ihr nach Berücksichtigung findet. Soweit ich weiß, gibt es da momentan noch ein paar Slots, die frei sind, also ist schon durchaus noch was zu machen, aber man sollte es nicht zu lange verpeilen. Die Daten dazu finden sich üblich unter www.cde, das ist irgendwo verlinkt. Wir betonen es auch nochmal in die Linkliste, genau den Link zum CFP. Wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr gute Vorträge habt, gerade im technischen Gebiet dann die einzureichen, wäre schön.
Wer noch nie dabei war, das ist zwar eine technische Veranstaltung, aber wir nehmen auch nicht technische Vorträge, solange sie cool und interessant sind. Also, wenn ihr was cooles und interessantes habt, kommt zu uns.
Also der Fokus des kongresses ist nicht sehr eng, sondern auf allem, was tatsächlich von interesse sein könnte, auf allem, wo Leute verblüfft sein können, dass sowas geht, sowohl technisch als auch politisch als auch künstlerisch. Also wenn ihr interessante, kreative Dinge habt, lest euch den CFP durch und dann folgt da den Anweisungen unseres Penta-Buffs, indem man diese Einreichungen reintut.
Also ich erinnere mich noch, dass wir beim CFP diesmal eingetragen haben, wir Atomkraftwerke fernsteuert. Da waren wir näher mit an der Realität, als wir gedacht haben, als wir das da reinschrieben.
Du weißt ja nicht, ob einer von denen nicht auf dem Kopf gerachtet war.
Genau, also.
Aber dazu können wir heute dieses Mal doch nichts sagen. Vielleicht in der nächsten Sendung sagen wir mal was zur Atomkraftwerke fernsteuern. Für diese Sendung ist es noch ein wenig früh und die Faktenlage zu dünnen. Ja, was haben wir noch? Die Demo am vergangenen Wochenende.
Freiheit statt Angst.
Die Freiheit statt Angst-Demo. Da waren sowas wie 7.500 Leute, also ungefähr ein Drittel von denen, was wir ja bei der Demo im Jahr davor hatten. Was denke ich mal auch sicherlich ein Ergebnis dessen ist, dass diese ganzen Themen mittlerweile so ein bisschen weichgespült sind. Die Regierung redet nun plötzlich mit uns.
Genau, das ist die Strategie der Regierung im Moment. Sie verbinden uns in irgendwelchen Enquete-Kommissionen und so. Da werden wir auch noch davon berichten.
Ja, die Enquete-Kommission eigentlich wollten wir aus der Enquete-Kommission von einem Insider berichten lassen, aber das müssen wir noch ein bisschen vertragen, damit wir dann die wirklich juicy stories bekommen können. Insofern verschieben wir sie noch ein bisschen. Aber ich denke, genau diese geschichten wie diese Enquete-Kommissionen haben durchaus einen Einfluss darauf, wie sich jetzt die allgemeine Stimmungslage entwickelt und wie sehr die Leute willen, auf die Straße zu gehen. Es gibt auch keinen akuten Aufreger. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die vorratste Ansprechung gerade wieder beschlossen wurde.
Na ja, es gibt LA. Also es gibt schon Punkte, aber es gibt nicht.
Es gibt schon Punkte, aber keiner hat eben diese Betroffenheit, wie jetzt gerade hier parallel zu unserer Aufnahme laufen noch die letzten reste der Anti-Atomen-Kundgebungen hier in Berlin, wo mal so entspannt 100.000 Leute auf der Straße waren, was halt schon eine völlig andere Dimension ist. Und wo man auch sehen kann, was die Leute wirklich intensiv betrifft in ihrem persönlichen Sicherheits- oder Bequemlichkeitsempfinden. Und die Datenschutz und sonstigen Themen gehören da offensichtlich noch nicht ganz genau dazu und da müssen wir nur noch ein bisschen dran arbeiten.
Da müssen wir aber hin und mit eurer Mithilfe hoffentlich.
Ja, Leute auf der Straße, also es ist ja in vielen Städten mittlerweile gibt es so komische Demos. In Stuttgart wird gegen diesen Bahnhofsbau in großer Zahl demonstriert.
Es gibt in Hannover übrigens, das ist nicht nur eine Stuttgart-Saal, es gibt in Hannover auch gerade so ein Projekt, wo die landesregierung ihren Plenarsaal neu bauen will, obwohl der alte eigentlich noch renoviert werden könnte. Und das ist auch total schlachsinnig, weil die da die Bildungsausgaben zusammenkürzen, aber parallel dann eben doch Geld haben, um ihren Plenarsaal mit irgendeiner Architekturausschreibung zu machen. Ich würde sagen, kümmert euch mal auch in eurem bundesland darum, oder in eurem Land, wenn ihr außerhalb Deutschlands seid. Das ist nicht nur eine Sache von Stuttgart oder Berlin, sondern das ist auch Lokalpolitik, ist auch spannend. Da muss man sich auch einbringen.
Was ich interessant finde, ist, was da so viele Leute auf die Straße gehen, gerade in Stuttgart. Stuttgart ist ja nun die berufennachspießigste Stadt in Deutschland. Und wenn wir hier in Berlin Probleme haben mit Leuten, die die lokalen Gepflogenheiten nicht so richtig verstehen und denken nur, weil sie hier eine Wohnung gekauft haben, können sie jetzt diktieren, wie laut die Musik gespielt wird im Park.
Die beschimpfen wir hier mal als Stuttgarter.
Insofern Schwaben. Genau, unsere Importschwaben. Und insofern ist es schon interessant, wenn plötzlich dann im schwäbischen Kernland, in Zentralschwaben sozusagen, in Stuttgart die Leute zu 30.000 auf die Straße gehen, um gegen so ein Bauprojekt zu protestieren.
Und die lassen sich ja nicht abbringen davon, dass die Regierung sagt, die Sache sei schon unterschrieben und nicht mehr umkehrbar. Das fand ich ja besonders schön. Normalerweise ist dann ja Schluss. Also wenn so ein Argument kommt wie, wir haben das schon unterschrieben, wir können jetzt nicht zurück. Und wir haben auch schon den Baum abgerissen. Und wir haben auch schon irgendwie blablabla. Da haben die sich überhaupt nicht von aufhalten lassen, die einfach weiter demonstrieren.
interessant ist ja diese geschichte, die der Spiegel hatte vor zwei, drei Wochen, hat er dieses Titel mit der protestrepublik, wo sie...
Ja, die ganzen Querulanten.
Genau, die ganzen Querulanten demonstrieren und so. Das Land wird unregierbar und so weiter und so fort. interessant ist ja, dass genau dieser protest, der jetzt da hochkommt, der sehr unspezifisch und differenziert, auch teilweise einfach gegen die Politik ist so. Und diese sarrazin-geschichte, die passt ja insofern ganz gut rein, weil sie darauf reitet, dass die Leute mit der Art und Weise, wie sie regiert werden, nicht mehr zufrieden sind. Dass sie oft Probleme, die da bestehen, dass da nicht eingegangen wird, dass versucht wird, diese Probleme, egal welche Art sie sind, ob sie Atomkraftwerke sind oder empfundene Missstände mit Migrations- und Integrationspolitik, dass die versucht werden, ja, also diesen Unbehagenen zu artikulieren. Und der Sarrazin, der da getan hat, ist auf dieser Welle zu reiten. Und wenn wir uns ein bisschen umgucken im europäischen Ausland, sehen wir ja, dass da ein Großteil der Länder ringsum uns auch solche rechten Bewegungen haben. Also das Hervorstechens zum Beispiel ist, glaube ich, in Niederland.
gesamt Europa eigentlich, also auch in Frankreich. Und sogar in Dänemark gibt es Nazis plötzlich.
Ja und in Österreich, nein, in Österreich nicht, in Ungarn gibt es Nachfolger dieser Fallkreuzler-Bewegung, also richtige Nazis. In Niederland wiederum ist es so, dass die Rechte...
Die Österreicher waren ja sogar Vorreiter mit Heilern.
Stimmt, die Österreicher waren Vorreiter mit Heilern, das ist richtig. Aber interessant ist ja, dass genau Österreich und Niederlande, dass es halt nicht so richtige Nazis sind, sondern halt so neue Rechte, die in dieser Art und Weise und in dieser Form bisher noch nicht so richtig da waren, die sich auch so einer Typisierung gewissermaßen entziehen. In Berlin haben wir es ein bisschen gesehen bei dem, kann man schon sagen, doch ja, Volksaufwallen gegen den Bau einer Moschee in Prankow. Wenn man sich dann die Realitäten anguckt, was da tatsächlich passiert wurde, nachdem diese Moschee gebaut wurde, man sieht die nicht, die steht hinter einem Kentucky Fried Chicken irgendwo an der Autobahnauffahrt und es sieht halt so aus, als würde der Kentucky Fried Chicken halt so eine komische Kugeldach haben. Die Leute haben sich da endlos aufgeregt und da gab es Differenzsituationen und Unterschaftensammlungen. Die hatten halt wirklich alle Angst vor muslimischer Überfremdung.
Wobei dir noch relativ klein war im Vergleich zu den Kölner Moschee, die ja wirklich einmal durch die boulevardpresse getragen wurde. Das war halt auch Sommer noch.
Ja, interessant an dieser Moschee in pankow-geschichte ist, dass die jetzt jemand hochgespürt hat, einem Stadtgewitz, der CDU-Abgeordnete in Pankow war und rausgeflogen ist, weil er den Wilders eingeladen hat.
Na, du brauchst ein bisschen Hintergrund noch dazu. Also Pankow ist nicht traditionell nur Hochburg, der CDU.
Nee, die CDU ist in Pankow eine Splitterpartei. Pankow wurde eigentlich in der Regel bei den Wahlen zwischen SPD und den Linken entschieden. Mittlerweile ist die Grünen fast gleich auf mit denen. Also so ein Drittel, Drittel, Drittel, Drittel, linke SPD, Grüne und dann noch irgendwo so eine Splitterpartei, irgendwie CDU und NPD. Aber interessant ist genau dieser Punkt, dass er den Wilders eingeladen hat. Der Wilders ist ja in Holland jetzt der aufstrebende neue Star von so einer nio-rechten Bewegung.
Nach Pimp-Vortümen, Vortümen, Vortümen. Und die, angefangen hat es da eben mit dem Mord an den Pimp-Vorteilen, dem ja einem sehr flamboyanten Schwulen, der, ja man kann so sagen, gegen Muslime war, weil Muslime Probleme mit Schwulen haben und das ist so ein bisschen eine neue Bewegung, dass die Rechten gar nicht so Nationalrechte sind, wie das ja früher immer war, dass quasi die Ausländerfeindlichkeit mit einem, mit einer Erhöhung des Nationalzusammengefühls erkauft werden sollte, das ist nicht mehr so, sondern die sind weniger für quasi eine Abspaltung der Niederlande aus der EU, als sie halt generell sich und ihre liberalen Werte, da sind durchaus liberale Werte vorhanden, vor denen aus ihrer Sicht eben steinzeitlichen Moslems verteidigen wollen.
Ich glaube, dass das nur die politische Front ist, weil die politisch akzeptabel ist.
Du meinst, sie sind eigentlich schon national?
Na, was die ansprechen, ist schon ein ziemlich dumpfer Nationalismus oder so ein dumpfer Kultur-Nationalismus, der dann mobilisiert werden kann. Also das wird nach außen hin so ein wir haben ja eigentlich nichts gegen Auslei, sondern nur gegen Muslime, die uns in unserer freiheitlichen Lebensweise einschränken wollen. diese Argumentation ist ja tatsächlich nur der, sagen wir mal, der intellektuelle Vorbau, der politisch irgendwie akzeptabel wäre, mit dem man auch mehr Leute erreichen kann. Wenn du dir aber anguckst, was da für Leute rumlaufen, wer da mobilisiert wird und wer sich da angesprochen fühlt, war ja bei dieser sarah-thing-geschichte so, dann sieht man schon sehr deutlich, dass es schon bis rein in dieses nationale Potenzial reingeht. interessant ist ja, dass die Nazis, also die richtigen Nazis, die NPD und so, die haben alle nicht so richtig viel Spaß an dieser sarah-thing-geschichte, weil sie sehen, dass ihnen da ihr ganzes Potenzial abgesaugt wird, weil es tatsächlich dann in diese Richtung geht, dass so eine protestbewegung oder wie auch immer entsteht.
Naja, also das ist schon ein Unterschied. Also wenn man sich den Haider anguckt als Vergleich, der war durchaus auch national, hat sich als landeshauptmann auch feiern lassen und nebenan haben sie da auch ein Denkmal gebaut und der war auch bemüht, Kohle in seine Regionen zu kriegen, in Abgrenzung zu anderen Regionen im Lande. Also das ist schon ein Unterschied und ich weiß nicht, ob man sich das so einfach machen kann, dass man sagen kann, der benutzt das nur als Maske, um diese Leute anzuziehen. Oder man weiß ja gar nicht, ob er die Leute überhaupt anziehen will. Vielleicht hat er ja seine Agenda und ist selber nicht zufrieden damit, was dafür Leute kommen, aber benutzt sie eben, weil das ein Hebel ist für ihn politisch.
Na es gibt ja ein klares Unterscheidungskriterium. Wie will das bewegen, ist definitiv nicht antisemitisch. Und auch der größte Teil dessen, was sich jetzt da so in diese Sarrazin-Ecke sammelt, ist halt auch nicht antisemitisch. Wohingegen die klassischen traditionellen Rechten sind halt antisemiten. Wilders hingegen hat durchaus intensive Kontakte und Support aus Israel. Wohingegen so die richtigen Nazi-Leute, die hatten ja dann normale Autounfälle. Also die hatte, wenn sich da immer jemand sich rauskristallisierte, der so aussah, als könnte er der neue Führer werden, dann hatte der einen komischen Autounfall.
Der Wilders hat ja auch eine Immigrantin als Lebensgefährte aus der Ukraine, ne?
Wichtiger Punkt, Ukraine, dass nämlich genau diese selektive Ausländerfeindlichkeit, die sich da äußert, also weniger ein Herkunftsnationalismus, als ein Kulturraumnationalismus ist. Zu sagen, bei den Russen oder den Ukrainern haben wir eigentlich nicht so ein Problem, weil die fahren im Straßenbild nicht auf, ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Also diese gefühlte Überfremdung hat auch sehr viel damit zu tun, ob die Leute genauso aussehen, wie die Leute, die sich überfremdet fühlen. Und Russen oder Ukraine, da siehst du das erstmal nicht an. Wenn du nicht ganz genau hinguckst, dann siehst du vielleicht, dass sie ein bisschen kantigere gesichter haben, aber das ist völlig normal. Das passt völlig ins Straßenbild. Und die sind auch nicht, selbst wenn sie so eine relativ abgeschlossene Kulturräume pflegen, was in Berlin zum Beispiel durchaus heftig der Fall ist. Da gibt es Saunen und Kneipen und so, die sind halt fest in der Hand von Russen, aber da stört sich niemand dran. interessiert niemand.
Na, das ist auch nicht gesund, sich daran zu stören.
Pff, nee, ach, da gibt es auch so richtig Kulturvereine und so. Die sind halt nicht so fremd, die Entfernung zur Eigenkultur ist da geringer und deswegen stört sich die Leute da weniger dran.
Ist das nicht vielleicht einfach nur pragmatisch, also, dass die eigentlich schon voll ausländerfeindlich wären, wenn das irgendwie realistisch wäre? Was meinst du?
Äh, tja, schwer zu sagen. Also, du meinst, sie sind nur nicht gegen die Russen, weil sie sie nicht erkennen?
Sie sagen es doch nicht. Na, weil, ich meine, ein paar Verbündete brauchst du ja schon. Also, selbst die Nazis haben ja Verbündete gehabt. Nicht viele, aber ein paar.
Ja, gut, also kann sein, ich denke mal, dass das nicht so strategisch ist, sondern wirklich mehr so aus dem Bauch rauskommt und so ein gefühlter Ding ist. Und die, meine ich, wird der Sarrazin ja angesprochen, na, weiß nicht, ob er es angesprochen hat, aber zumindest die Diskussionen, die durch entstanden sind, das ist ja schon, wie sieht eigentlich eine Einwanderungspolitik in Deutschland aus? Und Deutschland hat halt, ähnlich wie die Niederlande, über viele Jahre hinweg keine sinnvolle Einwanderungspolitik gehabt. Also, wir haben uns nicht darum gekümmert, wer kommt da, unter welchen Kriterien lassen wir Leute rein, sondern das war halt so eine diffuse Mischung, die halt am Ende nicht dazu fühlte, dass das eigentlich ein Problem, nämlich, dass unsere Demografie im Einmaß ist und dass hier zu wenig Leute nachwachsen, als dass irgendwie die wirtschaftlichen Strukturen und die gesellschaftlichen Strukturen weiter erhalten werden können. dieses Problem wurde halt nicht angegangen.
Naja, das ist ja auch ein neues Problem. Ich meine, bis vor ein paar Jahren gab es ja noch die Babyboomer.
Nee, also das Problem ist halt mindestens seit der Wende vollkommen absehbar.
Ja, na klar, aber das ist eher so unsere Einwanderungspolitik, die geht bis in die 50er zurück.
Na gut, es gab auch keine Einwanderungspolitik.
Mit den Gastarbeiter, genau.
Das war auch keine Einwanderungspolitik.
Ja, aber das war eher so eine humanistische Sache. Wir müssen den Leuten helfen.
Gastarbeiter.
Ja, erst Gastarbeiter. Aber danach ist das immer ausgerichtet gewesen auf was zu suchen.
Das ist richtig. Aber eben genauso gab es halt keine Einwanderungspolitik, sondern nur so eine irgendwie Einsickerungsmöglichkeit oder so. Genau. Also selbst die Gastarbeiter, wie der Name ja schon sagt, sollten ja wieder gehen. Nur natürlich sind die nicht wieder gegangen, nachdem halt in der Tür die Militärligatur anfing und da extrem ungemütlich wurde. Und klar war das schwierig, hier wieder zurückzukehren, wenn man einmal raus ist. Dann haben die halt ihre Familien nachgeholt, was die ihnen natürlich niemand verdenken kann. Und eben genau aber diese Einsicht, dass wir eigentlich ein Einwanderungsland sein müssen, wie z.B. Kanada. Wenn man sich hier von einer kanadischen Botschaft hier in den Leuten um, die keilen richtig Menschen. Die sagen, hey, du bist so irgendwie 35, gut ausgebildet, hast Erfahrung, in deinem Beruf willst du nicht nach Kanada kommen. Hier ist diese lustige kleine Visitenkartin mit der URL von dem Online-Einreise-Formular-Beantragungsding. Da klickst du an, wie viel Berufserfahrung du sofort hast und dann gibt es so ein punktesystem. Und dann fällt heraus, wenn du über einen bestimmten Punkt der Anzahl bist, dann laden sie dich halt zum gespräch ein und dann hast du eine hohe Chance, dass es genehmigt wird. Dann gibt es halt noch so ein paar Sachen mit sprachtests und so, die du halt absolvieren musst und dann kannst du dahin. Also die haben halt klare Vorstellungen, die politisch festlegen, was sie für Leute haben wollen. Sie sehen halt, wo sie Mängel haben und es wird halt erwartet, dass du dich vollständig integrierst. Du musst halt Englisch, Französisch am besten beides sprechen. Und zum Beispiel in Norwegen ist es ähnlich, da ist es auch so, dass die ganz klare Regeln haben, zu sagen, hier sind die Leute, die wir haben wollen. Wir haben einen Sprachkurs, der vom Staat finanziert, aber du musst dann halt nach drei Jahren oder so, musst du halt eben doch Norwegisch sprechen können.
Eine echte Hürde übrigens.
Das ist nicht so schwer. Also, Norwegisch ist eine designsprache. Also, die hatten da, nachdem Norwegen sich dann bildete so, hatten die ein ernsthaftes Problem, dass die Sprache so zersplittert war und teils nur alle so ein paar Dialekte waren. Dann haben sie sich halt zu ihren professoren hingesetzt und haben eine Sprache designen lassen, Nynorsk. Und dementsprechend ist die auch einigermaßen straightforward im Vergleich zu anderen Sprachen. Also jetzt nicht so wie, keine Ahnung, Baskisch oder so, wurde halt irgendwie so mit so völlig abstrusen Konstruktionen. Okay, jetzt kriegen wir bestimmt Kloppe von Mahab, wenn wir aber auf Bass gesprungen haben.
Aber Litauisch ist auch okay.
Esnisch ist noch ein Problem zum Beispiel. Esnisch ist halt auch so eine Sprache, wo man, was man schon wirklich wollen. Gut, aber jedenfalls um auf den Punkt zurückzukommen. Das Problem an dieser ganzen Debatte gerade ist eigentlich, dass ich nicht sehe, dass sie das, und auch diesen rechten Bewegungen, diesen neu rechten Bewegungen, dass ich nicht so richtig sehe, dass die dazu führt, dass es eine rationale Einladungspolitik geben wird. Also dass es nicht dazu dahin kommt, dass wir eine Einladungspolitik kriegen, und zwar in wirklich kurzer Zeit, die dazu führt, dass die Leute hierher kommen, die wir brauchen, um diese Land weiter betreiben zu können die nächsten 50, 100 Jahre. Sondern dass es dazu führen wird, dass der allgemeine Eindruck bei Leuten, die wir eigentlich hier haben wollen, würden, so als Land, ist, irgendwie diese Deutschen sind ausländerfeindlich, die werden immer ausländerfeindlich bleiben. Und eigentlich will ich da nicht hin, weil keine Ahnung, wann die wieder anfangen, irgendwie mit Moscheen abbrennen.
Naja, das hängt schon auch von dem Land ab, von dem du kommst. Also es gibt auch, also wenn du hier zum Beispiel als Amerikaner oder Britte rumgehst, dann triffst du nicht auf viel Ausländerfeindlichkeit.
Es hängt von deiner Hautfarbe. Ja klar.
Es gibt da auch noch die Sache, dass natürlich verschiedene Länder verschiedene Bevölkerungsdichten haben und dass Deutschland da zwar nicht, sagen wir, mit irgendwelchen Stadtstaaten mithalten kann, aber wir sind schon immer Europa-Vergleich relativ weit vorne. Also kein Vergleich zu sagen, wir Norwegen.
Nein, gehen wir nach Brandenburg.
Nach wie einem Brandenburg hast du weite Flächen. Nein, ich sage nicht, dass wir... Ich sage nicht, dass wir keinen Platz haben. Ich sage nur, die Bevölkerungsdichte pro Quadratkilometer ist von Deutschland schon... Ja, dann haben sie ab. Aber der Punkt ist einfach, dass Einwanderung bei uns nicht so als was gewolltes gesehen wird, sondern als was geduldetes. Dass man sagt, naja, wir machen mal eine Ausnahme, aber Leute reinlassen ist eigentlich nichts, was hier so als Ziel gesehen wird. Dass wir da was gewinnen.
Muss es aber, weil irgendjemand wird am Ende irgendwie unsere Exoskelette warten müssen, wenn wir alt sind.
Man muss unseren Rollstuhl schieben.
Ich hoffe, dass es dann kein Rollstuhl mehr ist. Ich will noch nicht ein Exoskelett haben. Bitte nicht.
Eigentlich wird es so einen Gravitationsnegator haben.
Ich könnte gerne einen 3 Meter hohen Exoskelett mit ungefähr, so ein 500 PS wäre ein angemessener.
Bis dahin haben wir die Energieprobleme gelöst.
Hoffen wir doch mal. Da kommen wir noch später drauf, die Energieprobleme. Anyway, also der Punkt ist für mich, dass diese Debatte dazu führt, dass die eigentlich notwendige Debatte, nämlich die darum, dass Deutschland ein Einwanderungsland sein muss, wenn wir unseren Lebensstand, unsere Infrastruktur aufrechterhalten wollen, dass die weiter vertagt wird. Und das ist eigentlich das Verbrecherische daran, dass eben diese Debatte nicht dahin führt, dass wir sagen, wir wollen gerne Einwanderungsland werden, sondern dass der Eindruck, den die Menschen da bekommen, die wir hier haben wollen, eigentlich ist, naja, diese Deutschen wollen halt immer noch nicht und gehen halt woanders hin. Es gibt genügend Länder, die genau dieselbe Demografieprobleme haben und verstanden haben, dass sie Einwanderungsland werden sollen. Also die USA zum Beispiel haben das Problem nicht, ne?
Die USA haben eine ganz lustige Regelung. Das ist relativ schwer, da eine Green Card zu kriegen. Aber eine der Möglichkeiten ist, dass du vorweisen kannst, dass du eine Million auf dem Konto hast.
Gibt es interessanterweise in Deutschland auch?
Tatsächlich.
Ja, es gibt da so eine investitionsklausel. Gibt es in anderen auch in Bulgarien zum Beispiel, wo es sogar billiger ist. Ich glaube, der billigste EU-Pass ist, für 450.000 investment zu kriegen und so. Also man kann es eigentlich...
Du musst es ja nicht investieren, du musst es ins Land bringen. Also naja, natürlich.
Ja gut, aber es gibt da eben einen anderen...
Aber ich meine, die Idee, dass du quasi als Land daran interesse hast, Millionäre anzuziehen, das ist schon eigentlich ein offensichtlicher Schritt, den eigentlich alle gehen sollten.
Also die spannende Frage ist halt eben, und wenn wir uns angucken, wohin die Reise geht so, dann sehen wir, dass Deutschland bisher die Globalisierungsvergleiche gut überstanden hat, dadurch, dass wir hier immer noch Manufacturing haben. Hier werden immer noch Industrieanlagen hergestellt und Maschinen und Lachsichtmaschinen und Autos und solche Sachen so. Also so Sachen, die die chinesen bisher noch nicht bauen.
Na und durch die EU. Wir haben es halt geschafft, über die EU unsere Nachbarn zu kannibalisieren.
Wir haben uns dadurch einen Markt geschaffen, der vergleichsweise ähnlich groß ist wie die USA.
Und der sich nicht wehren kann. Die müssen unsere Scheiße kaufen, die können keine Strafzölle machen.
Na die wollen auch nicht.
Und wir haben verschiedene Tricks gefunden, wie wir die anderen EU-Staaten dazu bringen, uns unseren Scheiß abzukaufen.
Na ja, gut.
Also ich bin der Meinung, wenn wir das nicht gemacht hätten, dann wären wir heute genauso Globalisierungsopfer.
Das denkst du sicherlich so, ja.
Kommt das denn, dass es trotzdem im Fernsehen zumindest so aussieht, als wenn es ausländerfeindliche Hetzer dieser Regime sind, wenn die eigentlich gar nicht generell ausländerfeindlich sind, sondern differenzierte...
Wen meinst du jetzt?
Na, also insbesondere den Wilders natürlich, aber auch der Sarkozy, der passt auch so ein bisschen. Mit seiner Roma-Ausweisung jetzt...
Das ist national immer sehr verschieden. Also Nierland ist ja an sich im Prinzip ein sehr tolerantes Land. Und die haben ja auch Kolonien. Die haben halt das Problem, dass bei denen über viele Jahre die ganzen Einwanderer gelandet sind, die alle anderen nicht haben wollten. Also die hatten auch praktisch keine Ananusspolitik und sie haben keine sinnvollen Prinzipien gehabt, um die Leute zu integrieren. Und sie wollten sie auch nicht dazu zwingen. Es war halt schon ein Liberalismus-Ding.
Aber das ist eigentlich lustigerweise bei den anderen Ländern mit Kolonien genauso. Also die Briten haben richtig viele Pakistanis und Inder.
Die haben zwar intern noch einen starken britischen Nationalismus, aber dadurch, dass die schon so lange kolonial gemacht sind.
Die haben es andersrum gemacht. Die haben nicht die Einwanderer zum Englisch lernen gezwungen, sondern die haben noch als es Kolonie war, die Kolonie zum Englisch lernen gezwungen. Die Franzosen haben ähnliches Problem mit ihren Kolonien. Die haben auch zwar strenge Asylregelungen, aber wenn du aus einer Kolonie kommst, dann kannst du umziehen nach Frankreich. Oder war zumindest Jahr oder so. In Niederlanden sehe ich das genauso. Da kommt es natürlich her, dass es in diesen Ländern große Bevölkerungsgruppen gibt aus den Kolonien jeweils. Und dass die, wenn die zusammen rüberkommen, dann auch das leichter haben, wenn sie sich hier zusammentun.
Das ist zwangsläufig so. Du kannst es einfach extrapolieren, wenn du versuchst, in Berlin eine Wohnung zu finden, hast du einen nicht deutschen Nachnamen.
Dann findest du überhaupt nur in Weddingen was.
Da findest du präzise da nur was, wo den Leuten in die Häuser gehören, die keine Probleme mit nicht deutschen Nachnamen haben. Genauso ist es mit Jobs. Es ist schon so, dass durch diese immanente Fremdenfeindlichkeit der Deutschen oder auch der Franzosen diese Separierung befördert wird und dass sie im Alltag trotz aller Integrationsbemühungen einfach da ist. Und schwer zu reduzieren ist, wenn es nicht eine generelle Änderung der Ansichten darüber gibt, dass diese Leute uns in Zukunft finanzieren, wenn sie dann gern meinen. Das ist ein extrem schwieriges Thema. Das Problem ist am Ende, dass wir gerade wieder durch eine rezession fahren und sich genau da diese Themen wieder hochkochen. Also man kann sich das genau angucken, so in dem Umblick, wo es allen gut geht. interessiert sich niemand dafür, wie viele Ausländer am Land sind oder Menschen, die sich nicht in den Kulturkreis integriert haben oder nicht integrieren wollen. Sobald rezession da ist und die Leute Angst in ihre Arbeitsplätze haben, ist das das Erste, woran sie denken, naja, irgendwie könnte man noch rauswerfen, damit wir wieder mehr Arbeitsplätze haben. Ein völliger Verkenntnis der Tatsache, dass es nicht mehr lange dauern wird, bis wir hier zu viel Arbeit haben und nicht mehr nur Leute. Das wird nicht mehr so lange dauern.
Naja, vollbeschäftigung. Ich glaube, wir haben alles wegrationalisiert. Wir haben nie wieder genug Arbeit.
Nein, ich denke, das hat nicht so viel mit vollbeschäftigung zu tun, sondern einfach damit, dass der Anteil an dienstleistungsgeschichten, gerade auch im medizinischen Bereich, wenn du neulich mal wieder beim Arzt warst, warst du die schwestern, die da irgendwie rumlaufen, sind irgendwie alles Ukraine-erinnen oder...
Ja, das will ja auch jemand machen hier, ne?
Genau, das will ja auch jemand machen.
Da hast du auch nicht genug Geld für, um da richtig vonnehmen zu können. Also wir hatten noch eine these hier aufgestellt, die wir noch diskutieren wollten, nämlich ob das vielleicht inhärent aus der Globalisierung folgt, diese Fremdenfeindlichkeit, also nicht nur aus der rezession, sondern einfach generell aus der Globalisierung, dass man die ganze Zeit mit irgendwelchen ausländischen Gütern umgeben ist. Gut, die haben wir natürlich dann versuchen, teilweise eine deutsche Marke zu haben, aber das ist ja schon auffällig, dass überall mit den Scheinen raussteht und vielleicht sorgt das auch für so ein bisschen Abstoßung. Dass man das Gefühl hat, ich bin umzingelt. Was ja nicht so der Fall ist, wenn man nur inländische Güter um sich herum hat. Wie ist denn da vom Unterschied her DDR zur bundesrepublik? Das ist ja weniger ausgeprägt gewesen in der DDR. Gab es da mehr oder weniger Fremdenfeindlichkeit? Ich meine, da ging es den Leuten ja auch.
Das ging allen gleich schlecht.
Ja, eben.
Aber ich meine das.
Ist das eher Level-Trigger oder Edge-Trigger? Also ist es so die rezession, dass es dir schlechter als gestern geht? Oder ist es, dass es dir insgesamt schlecht geht?
Also die Fremdenfeindlichkeit in der DDR war immer sehr punktuell. Nämlich da, wo es mal Ballungen gab. Wir hatten im Osten primär größere Gruppen Ausländer aus Vietnam, aus Mosambik und aus Angola und aus Kuba. Das waren so die vier großen Gruppen, die hier im Rahmen von irgendwelchen Arbeitsaustauschabkommen hergeholt wurden. Zum einen sollten die in der Wirtschaft arbeiten, teilweise auch für einigermaßen, selbst für Ostverhältnisse, aber auch für löhne, was für WD wiederum ok war, weil bei ihnen zuhause noch viel beschissener war als in der DDR. Also viel beschissener. Und zum anderen war es auch so eine solidaritätsgeschichte, Solidarität mit den Entwicklungsländern, war unter anderem auch, dass man ihnen Sachen beigebracht hat. Viele von denen haben hier studiert und auch gut Deutsch gelernt.
Gab es da so eine Neid, die nehmen uns die Arbeitsplätze weg?
Das war, glaube ich, primär so eine, die nehmen uns die Frauen weg-Neid. Gerade gegen die Afrikaner, die waren halt exotisch, das war schon sehr deutlich. Das waren die Sachen, wo es am meisten getriggert wurde, als Auslöser von, wenn es mal so Ausbrüche gab. Die Stasi war da immer hart hinterher. Es war nicht so, dass die das quälen haben lassen, sondern die haben das ziemlich brutal aufgeklopft. Das war aber schon durchaus ein Trigger für das Erstarken der DDR-Neonazi-Szene, die sich dann in den 80ern bildete. Was die Stasi überhaupt nicht verstanden hat, weil wir waren ja der antifaschistische Staat. Das antifaschistische Deutschland, das es da plötzlich Neonazis gab, das war für die völlig unverständlich. diese these mit den Waren finde ich interessant. Ich kann die jetzt noch nicht so ganz nachvollziehen, aber ich glaube, diese inhärente Angst, dass hier bald nichts mehr zu Wirtschaften sein wird, weil sowieso alles nach China geht, die kann da durchaus was mit zu tun haben. Vielleicht nimmt es dann ab, wenn der Transport von dem Zeug hierher schwieriger wird, wenn die Globalisierung wieder ein bisschen sich runterfährt.
Da haben wir auch noch etwas zu später. Jetzt machen wir hier noch die Amis. Die Amis sind ja auch eine konzentriert sind.
diese Tea party-geschichte, ja.
Das ist nur teilweise Ausländerfeindlichkeit. Die Amerikaner haben so eine ganz witzige Sache. Die haben ja auch einen bundesstaat wie wir. Und sie haben auch einzelne bundesländer. Da gibt es immer die Idee, dass die bundesländer, zum Beispiel hat die Bayerische Verfassung auch noch die todesstrafe drin, aber das wird halt von der bundesverfassung negiert. Aber das gibt es auch in Amerika. deswegen ist die Bewegung von den Konservativen meistens, die gibt den Ländern mehr Macht. Weil dann die einzelnen Länder, also der bundesstaat ist ja immer so eine Mittelung aus den Werten aller. Und da gibt es dann eben keine wirklich radikalen Regelungen. Die gibt es nur in bundesländern wie Arizona oder Texas. Und deswegen sind die Konservativen immer darauf aus, den Ländern wieder mehr Macht zu geben und dem bundesstaat weniger. Und das ist quasi deren Argumentation. Und in Arizona sieht man ganz gut, was da aus werden kann. Das ist ja gerade die Vorderfront der Ausländerfeindlichkeit in Amerika. Wobei die eben auch nahe in Mexiko sind.
Das war dieses Land, wo es mittlerweile verboten ist, Wasser in der Wüste liegen zu lassen?
Genau, es gibt so eine humanitäre Bewegung. Die lassen Wasserflaschen in der Wüste liegen, damit die Einwanderer nicht verdorsten auf dem Weg auf der Wüste. Und da gibt es jetzt offiziell Polizisten, die danach suchen und die Leute dann aus dem Verkehr ziehen, wenn du dabei erwischt wirst, wie du da Wasser auslegst.
Das gilt ja gleich als Unterstützung des Menschenhandels oder so.
Genau, also das ist schon relativ heftig. Und da sieht man, dass so ein bundesstaat, auch wenn wir in Deutschland haben ja ein ähnliches Problem, aber bei uns fehlt so ein bisschen die Perspektive darauf, dass es eigentlich eine gute Sache ist, so eine bundesregierung zu haben. Weil wir haben ja auch verschiedene Werte in Deutschland. Wenn wir hier alle eine bayerische Verfassung hätten, das wäre ja schon nicht so witzig. Wenn die einzelnen Länder machen könnten, was sie wollen.
Wobei natürlich weniger die Verfassung ist, als wiederum die kulturellen Gegebenheiten und Geflogenheiten. Auf so einem bayerischen Bergdorf kann man sich in Berlin...
Da wirst du eben gefedert. Gefährt und gefedert....
kann man sich in Berlin immer schwer vorstellen, wie es da so ist.
Will man vielleicht auch nicht. Aber es ist eben auch trotzdem eine konservative Bewegung diese Tea Party. Und deren Hauptziel ist tatsächlich die Entmachtung der bundesregierung in Amerika. Damit jeder seine einzelnen faschistischen Sachen durchziehen kann. Und dann kann sich nämlich auch eine Mehrheit bilden, wenn Arizona jetzt vorangeht und gegen mexikanische Einwanderer vorgeht. Und wenn die anderen bundesländer an der Grenze zu Mexiko das auch machen, dann ist ja quasi Fakten geschaffen. Und das sind auch genau die bundesländer, die in Amerika am meisten das gegen die Mexikaner tun wurden. Das sind die, die eine Grenze dahin haben.
Ja, Mexiko, da passiert ja gerade so einiges. Also was wir ja gerade sehen, ist, dass der Drogenkrieg, den die da ausfechten, eskaliert immer weiter. Also wird da irgendwie jede zweite Woche oder so wird da einer von den großen Drogenbossen festgenommen. Und fragt sich so ein bisschen, was sie jetzt anders gemacht haben.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie binladen, fand ich. Da hieß es eine Weile lang auch, sie haben die rechte Hand binladensverhaftet. Und dann ist es so, naja, dann kann es ja nicht mehr lange dauern. Und so eine Woche später haben wir wieder die rechte Hand binladensverhaftet. Und da fragt man sich dann irgendwann, wie viel gibt es denn davon?
In Mexiko weiß man relativ genau, wie diese Kartelle funktionieren und wie die Strukturen da aussehen. Das ist nicht so undefiniert wie bei Al-Qaeda, weil da ist die ganze geschichte halt sehr detailliert bekannt. Also es gibt da zum Beispiel eine dieser Gruppen, die heißt da Los Cetas. Die ist eine sehr spannende Gruppe. Und zwar waren die Cetas eigentlich eine Sondereinheit der mexikanischen Polizei. So was ähnliches wie bei uns, so die GSG 9.
Ach du Scheiße, und die haben die selbstständig gemacht?
Die hat so richtig hoch ausgebildet mit irgendwie Special techniques und Waffen und Taktiken und solche Sachen. Und die haben sich dann irgendwann kollektiv mit dem Staat überworfen und haben hier ein Kartell aufgemacht, Los Cetas. Die deren Führer vom Staat ausgebildete, hochintelligente, hochtrainierte Polizisten waren, die dann losgegangen sind und irgendwie die anderen Kartelle da zum Teil irgendwie aus dem Markt gedrängt haben mit irgendwie brutalsten Methoden und irgendwie ihren üblichen Techniken. Die haben dann so richtig so filmreife Stunts gebracht, wie irgendwie so eine Kokainlieferung von den anderen übernehmen, so mit irgendwie 20 Mann hoch irgendwie abseilen und Hubschraubern und irgendwie so, also halt so richtig fette Stunts.
Na, wenn du gut ausgebildet bist und ihn nicht in die gesetze halten musst, dann geht viel, oder?
Geht viel, genau. Und auch die anderen Kartelle, die es da so gibt, sind relativ gut bekannt. Also da gibt es eine Menge Literatur und presse drüber. Und insofern ist es ein bisschen anders. Aber was die jetzt da offensichtlich tun, ist, nach und nach die momentanen Bosse dieser Kartelle verhaften. Und da fragt sich schon, was so ein bisschen anders ist jetzt. Auch noch dazu kommt, dass die Amis ja angefangen haben, die Grenze massiv mit Drohnen zu überwachen.
Na, erst haben sie diesen Zaun gebaut. Das war auch ein Rohrkrepierer von einem.
Völliger Fehlschlag, ja.
Das war ein völliger Fehlschlag. Nicht nur, dass der natürlich mit mexikanischem illegalen Einwanderer gebaut wurde. So, und dann gab es auch noch Rohstoffdiebstahl, weil der Zaun ja auch Stahl war.
Wie der die Linke.
Dann haben die Mexikaner den aufgesägt, aber nicht um durchzugehen, sondern um den Material zu verkaufen. Genau, super. Und das ganze war also eine fette teststellung von Boeing. Die haben da auch irgendwelche großen Überwachungstürme gebaut, aber es gab halt dann kein Budget mehr, um da Leute reinzusetzen. Also das war ein Fehlschlag vor dem Herrn. Und der nächste Schritt war irgendwelche Militia-ähnlichen Volksgruppen, die sich da tatsächlich hingestellt haben mit irgendwie selbst gekauften Sniper-Gewähnen in die Wüste, um da auch die Leute zu ballern. Das ging auch ein bisschen durch Fernsehen. Und dann hat die bundesregierung angefangen, da denen zu sagen, dass das nicht erwünscht ist und dass sie da nicht einfach Leute abknallen dürfen, auch wenn es illegale Almwanderer sind. Und dann hieß es, naja, dann müssen wir halt Militär einsetzen, nicht? Und dann gab es erst irgendwelche Flugzeuge, die da geguckt haben und jetzt eben Drohnen aus bestimmten Gründen.
Die Drohnen sind ja jetzt vom Department of Homeland Security. Und interessant ist ja, dass die Aufrüstung geht ja da massiv weiter. Also man kann da so lustige Statistik machen, wenn man mal nach der Anzahl von Gun-Shops sucht in den USA, in Google Maps mal Gun-Shop plotten und dann siehst du, die sind halt alle hinter der mexikanischen Grenze.
Ja, nicht aus Zufall und auch nicht um die Amerikaner zu bedienen, sondern deren beste Kunden sind die Mexikaner, die über die Grenze gehen, sich da bewaffnen. Die Kartelle sind alle mit amerikanischen Waffen.
Wie jetzt der mexikanische Präsident so schön gesagt hat, der dann meinte, wir haben da das Problem, dass wir direkt neben dem weltgrößten Drogenkonsumenten direkt neben dem weltgrößten Waffenexporteur sitzen.
Und jeder will den Drogen verkaufen und alle wollen durch unser Fenster zu ihnen. Da war wieder der Zensur pinkeln.
Da kann man ein paar Probleme kriegen, interessant. Also eigentlich war dieser Kaldoron doch eher so eine Ami-Marionette, dachte man bisher.
Ja, der war ja auch. Also der hat auch massiv Ärger im Inland, weil natürlich die Bevölkerung eigentlich den anderen gewählt hat. Da gab es auch riesige Wahlkampf, Wahlbetrugsvorwürfe und alles. Und ausgerechnet der hat jetzt die Schnauze voll. Ich denke mal, das ist mit vielen Puppen, das ist ja so. Wie hieß dieser Drogen-Boss noch einmal, der mit dem gesicht wie eine Ananas, den sie in den 80ern hochgenommen haben?
gesicht wie eine Ananas?
Der hat in den Jahren irgendwie einen üblen Nackenfall gehabt. Ich hab den Namen vergessen.
Ah, Neujäger.
Neujäger, genau.
Stimmt, den haben sie am Ende wieder eingeknastet mit ihren Special forces.
Ja, der hat seine Hauptstrafe abgesessen, aber sie haben ihn einfach nicht rausgelassen.
Das ist ganz großartig. Was die Amis jetzt tun, ist natürlich, das als Gelegenheit zu benutzen, hier alles auszuprieren, was sie haben, und die letzte Tendenz war, Drogen einzusetzen und die Grenzen zu überwachen.
Man muss es auch so ein bisschen als Technologie-Schweinezirkel begreifen, wie in der PC-Industrie. Da kommen so viele Neuerungen raus, noch bei den Drohnen, weil das eben eine neue Technologie noch ist, dass du immer, sobald du die gekauft hast, und wenn du dann ein halbes Jahr brauchst, bis die im Einsatz sind, sind die schon mal veraltet, gibt es die nächste Generation. Und dann musst du die irgendwo einsetzen, du hast die ja gekauft, und deswegen werden plötzlich immer mehr Plätze gefunden, wo man nicht auch eigentlich eine Drohne einsetzen wird.
Momentan kommen die Drohnenhersteller nicht hinterher mit Bauen. Die sind auf ungefähr zwei Jahre hinaus ausgebucht mit ihren Fertigungskapazitäten.
Aber das ist immer noch erstaunlich, was die da an Fortschritten noch einbauen. Also was die da an Optiken entwickelt haben, da legt es sich ja flach.
Nun ist es ja so, dass die andere Wetter, also die Kartelle, die haben ja auch angefangen mit diesen Schmuggel-U-Booten. Und jetzt gab es die ersten Gerüchte, dass die Kartelle auch Drohnen einsetzen, um Koks über die Grenze zu fliegen.
Wir haben einen Gerücht gefunden, dass sie die Drohnen in Israel kaufen. Das konnten wir jetzt leider nicht nachfinden. Aber es gibt tatsächlich Fotos von selbstbauten Leichtflugzeugen, also nicht wirklich Drohnen, aber so Ultraleichtflieger, und die fliegen halt unter dem Madaw. Und der eine Artikel, den ich da gefunden habe, der hat gesagt, so ein Kilo Koks kostet in Kolumbien 1700 Dollar. Und in Amerika kriegst du dafür 30.000.
Das ist schon eine Gewinnspanne, mit der man arbeiten kann.
Das ist eine Gewinnspanne. Da musst du einfach nicht viele Kilos dabei haben, um mit einem Flug quasi dein Jahr zu finanzieren. Das Flugzeug abzuzahlen und davon leben zu können.
Also die Dinger unbemannt zu schicken hat natürlich den großen Vorteil, dass dann jemand drin sitzt, den man verhören kann. Da finden sich dann sehr viel weniger traces zurück zu der Organisation, die es losgeschickt hat. Ich denke mal, dass das auch voll der Trend werden wird. Wir werden die ersten Drone Wars sehen, an der Grenze zwischen Amiland und Mexiko, wo die sich dann gegenseitig anfangen abzuschießen, die drohen. Wenn die Amis wissen, dass sie eine drohen, haben sie halt auch keine Hemmungen, die abzuschießen. Also sie hatten auch keine Hemmungen, die abzuschießen, wenn es Flugzeuge waren, wie wir wissen. Auch wenn amerikanische Pastoren drinnen gesessen haben, das hatten wir auch schon.
Also die letzten, die da noch bemannt fliegen, sind die CIA-Schmuggelflieger, von denen auch alle paar Jahre wieder in der Ruta kommt.
Wenn die nicht mittlerweile auch auf Unnummern umgestellt haben. Also ich meine, mit dem Global Hawk kannst du entspannt nach Kolomien zurück. diese Import-Export-Probleme sind natürlich... Die interessante Frage ist, wie lange es die halt noch geben wird.
Wir haben hier die provokante these, dass die Globalisierung in fünf bis zehn Jahren eh vorbei ist. Wegen Peak Oil unter anderem.
Ja, also wir haben ja gesehen jetzt in der letzten Wirtschaftskrise, wo der Ölverbrauch wieder mal dramatisch gefallen ist, nachdem er irgendwie schündelerregende Höhen erreicht hat und offensichtlich gegen das Fördervolumen gefahren ist, dass hinterher dieses gesamte Schiffsshipping und so und auch der Luftverkehr dramatisch eingebrochen ist. Müssen wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen erklären, was eigentlich dieses Peak Oil ist. Peak Oil ist ja nicht die Idee, dass das Öl dann alle ist, sondern dass das täglich verfügbare Fördervolumen sinkt. Also dass die Menge an Öl, die täglich dem Markt zur Verfügung steht, sinkt. Was dazu führt, dass wenn der...
Oder beziehungsweise stagniert.
Oder stagniert.
Das reicht schon, wenn sich stagniert, weil der Bedarf steigt.
Bei steigendem Verbrauch stagniert, wäre praktisch der selbe. Und die Auswirkungen davon sind natürlich, dass der Preis dann dramatisch in die Höhe schießt. Weil wenn der Markt unterversorgt ist und die Leute unbedingt Öl bekommen müssen, dann fängt der Preis etwas stärker an zu klettern als linear. Also da geht dann halt sehr viel mehr in die Höhe. Und wenn klar ist, dass es nicht mehr geht, also nicht mehr Öl da ist und anfängt die Wirtschaft wieder runterzufahren, geht es auch sehr viel schneller als linear. Und da gibt es diese interessante Theorie, die ich zuerst einmal gesehen habe in unserem heutigen Buchtipp mit dem schönen Namen The Last Oil Shock, a Survival Guide to the Imminent Extinction of Petroleum Men von David Strahan. Der hat die Theorie, dass er sagt, naja, also die Menge an förderbarem Öl fällt so ungefähr linear. Das heißt, es wird wie so ein langsam nach unten gehender Strich, zumindest für eine Weile. Und das Wirtschaftswachstum verläuft ja immer so sinusförmig. Also so halt geht hoch und dann geht's wieder runter, dann geht's hoch, wieder geht's wieder runter. Nur, dass diese Sinuskurve dann, wenn Peak Oil einsetzt und seiner Theorie nach hat's bereits eingesetzt oder wird in den nächsten Jahren einsetzen, geht diese Sinuskurve nicht mehr langsam nach oben wie bisher, sondern langsam nach unten. Das heißt also, dass das tatsächliche Wirtschaftswachstum in Menge an Output, in möglichem Output immer weiter fällt, aber nicht linear, sondern halt geht mal wieder hoch, bis die Wirtschaft wieder an die Menge des förderbaren Öls ranstößt, fällt dann wieder runter, weil die Wirtschaftskrise eintritt, wächst dann wieder hoch, aber in der Zeit ist die Menge des förderbaren Öls ja weiter gesunken.
Aber das ist eher so ein Sägezahn als ein Sinus, ne?
Ja gut, wie dann halt die Wirtschaftskurve läuft, ob das jetzt ein Sägezahn oder ein Sinus ist, hängt ja von verschiedensten anderen Parametern ab, aber die prinzipielle, die Erkenntnis ist eben, dass es genau so einen Pattern geben könnte. Insofern wird es interessant, wie jetzt die nächste boom-buzz-zeikel-geschichte aussieht und wie dann halt die absoluten Zahlen aussehen, die da hinten rauskommen.
Naja, also die interessante Idee daran ist ja, dass das schon passiert. Man kann ja, erstens konnte man sehen, als die Sowjetunion geplatzt ist, wie deren Industrievolumen in den Keller ging. Und wir haben das ja benutzt zum Spekulieren. Wir haben ja gesagt, diese CO2-Emissionshandelsscheiße, die basiert ja auf der Idee, dass die Russen viel mehr Industrie hatten. deswegen basieren ja auch die Zahlen im Vergleich, wozu wir senken müssen, sind alle von 1990 oder so. Und da ist ja die Idee, dass man einfach unseren Firmen mehr Zertifikate gibt, als sie brauchen und sie verschäuern das dann nach Russland. Also die Idee, dass quasi, wenn so ein Markt implodiert, dass es dann ruckartig ganz tief nach unten geht und dann wächst es wieder eine Weile und dann platzt es wieder, das kann man an Russland sehen. Und zweitens, unsere aktuelle rezession lässt sich so auch erklären. Und das ist eine Sache, die man sich mal durch den Kopf gehen lassen muss.
Also die spannende Frage ist ja, was passiert denn dann? Also wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen, nehmen wir an, die Theorie ist wahr. interessanterweise geht die bundeswehr auch davon aus, da gab es diese Peak Oil-Studie der bundeswehr, die es sogar bis in den Spiegel geschafft hat. Die es bis in den Spiegel geschafft hat und die doch relativ deutlich sagt, was da noch so zu erwarten ist, nämlich nicht viel. Die Frage ist, wo liegen denn halt eben genau die Schwachpunkte? Und eines der Dinge, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, war Shipping, also Güter durch die Gegend bewegen. Und wenn man sich so anguckt, wie die Volumina sich entwickelt haben in den letzten zwei Jahren, die sind halt dramatisch gefallen.
Also dramatisch die Zahl ist, dass die auf unter 5 Prozent gefallen sind. Das muss man sich mal vor Augen halten. Da standen fast die gesamte weltweite Shippingflotte, kurzfristig still, weil niemand mehr shippen wollte. Das war sogar so, dass du kostenlos Sachen shippen konntest für eine Weile. Also unglaubliche Zustände. Und es gab da Fotos von den ganzen Flotten, von riesenschiffen, die vor Singapurs Küste rumstanden. Mal sehen, ob ich die auch noch hier als Link finde. Aber das war ein richtig brutaler Zusammenbruch. Das war so, dass die ersten Werften zugemacht haben, weil es so aussah, als bleibt es jetzt so. Das hat sich aber relativ schnell wiederholt jetzt.
Der Grund dafür war ja, dass die Transportkosten nicht so hoch waren. Das war sicherlich ein Grund, weswegen die dann irgendwann anfingen, langsamer zu werden. Aber dieser Abschluss kann man ja daher, dass niemand mehr Handelskredite vergeben wollte. Handel funktioniert ja in der Regel so, dass man Sachen auf Kredit kauft in China, die dann hier teuer verkauft und dann den Kredit wieder zurückzahlt. So eine normale Handelsfinanzierung. Letter of Credit ist da so ein Terminus-Ding. Kannst du mal nachgucken. Das funktioniert halt so, dass man schließt den Kaufvertrag und der Kunde sagt zu seiner Bank, hier bestätige mal bitte dem, dass genügend Geld da ist. Und dann geht man mit dem Zettel von der Bank des Kunden zu seiner Bank, bekommt den Kredit für die Vorfinanzierung der Ware und dann wird hinterher, wenn die beiden Kredite gegeneinander verrechnet und die Ware geliefert. Und niemand wollte mehr diese Letter of Credit ausstellen, weil keine Bank die anderen mehr getraut hat.
Also um mal zu visualisieren, wie leer die Containerschiffe waren, es gibt tatsächlich mehrere Fälle, wo Firmen einfach ihre Ware da nicht abgeliefert haben, weil sie das Schiff eh für nichts anderes gebraucht haben und weil der Warenpreis, insbesondere bei Öl ist es passiert, aber auch bei Weizen, die haben einfach gesagt, naja, wenn ich das Schiff jetzt hier ein Jahr stehen lasse, also schon in langfristigen Größenordnungen, wenn ich das Schiff mit dem Öl jetzt hier ein Jahr stehen lasse, dann kostet es bestimmt mehr als jetzt. Und dass das überhaupt in der Wege gezogen wird, das sagt ja schon einiges über den Markt aus.
Wir haben uns noch mal ein bisschen angeguckt, womit werden eigentlich diese Schiffe durch die Gegend gefahren. Das ist ja auch immer eine interessante Frage. Und das ist eine ganz gruselige Angelegenheit. Also so ein Handelsschiff oder so ein Containerschiff oder ein Tanker, die fahren mit sogenannten Schweröl. Schweröl ist kurz gesagt das, was unübrig bleibt in der erdöl-destille, nachdem der ganze rest, den man sonst benutzen kann, raus ist. Also das ist halt so kurz über Straßentier.
Man soll vielleicht kurz erklären, wie so ein Teil funktioniert.
Wie so eine erdöl-destille funktioniert.
Genau, also das ist eine Art Hochofen, ne?
Nee, das ist kein Hochofen, das ist halt ein senkrecht stehender großes Rohr, in dem verschiedene Temperaturzonen sind und die Erdöl wird ja gecrackt. Also da werden halt über eine Reihe von chemischen Cracking-Reaktionen werden aus den Kohlenwasserstoffen kürzer Kettegekohlenwasserstoffe abgespalten, die dann halt verwendet werden können. Das sind so ein bisschen Benzin oder Etan oder halt diesel. Und die schweren Sachen, die sich halt nicht wirklich gut cracken lassen, die bleiben halt unten übrig. Ganz unten bleibt das übrig, weil das am Ende dann in den Straßenbau kommt. In den Straßenbau kommt. Und so direkt darüber ist Schweröl. Das ist halt eine extrem zähflüssige, super schwarze, stinkende Pampe, die man, damit man sie überhaupt pumpen kann, erst mal auf 50 Grad erwärmen muss. Das heißt, sie müssen diese Tanks, in denen sie das Zeug bewegen, und so müssen sie halt erwärmen. Man kann sich das ungefähr so vorstellen, als wenn man einen Straßentier verbrennt. Also ungefähr so die, der Grad von Leckerheit, den findet man da so.
Naja, eine Sache, die man vielleicht erwähnen muss, wenn wir alle bleifreies Benzin tanken, das heißt, dass das Blei runtersickert. Das ist ja nicht weg oder wird irgendwo eingegraben, sondern das landet dann genau in diesem Schweröl und wird von den Schiffen verballert.
Nein, das bei dem Schwefel ist das der Fall. Der Blei ist ja ein Adjektiv, das später dazugesetzt wurde.
Beim Schwefel ist das okay.
Genau, also nicht das Blei, sondern der Schwefel. Und der Schwefel landet in der Tat tatsächlich in diesen Schwerölen. Die bestehen teilweise aus 2-3% Schwefel. Also richtig super ultra-widerlich. Und damit werden unsere Container durch die Gegend gefahren. Und das Zeug ist auch vergleichsweise billig, weil es fällt ab. Und es wird auch in gigantischen Mengen verbrannt. Was hattest du für eine Zahl?
Ich hatte da einen Artikel gefunden, da heißt es das größte Containerschiff der Welt, die Maersk, die pumpt alleine so viele Schadstoffe in die Luft, wie 30 Kleinstarten zusammen, die drei wenigsten. Und nun ist es ja so, dass diese Containerschiffe hauptsächlich in internationalen Wässern fahren. Das heißt, umweltschutzgesetze der einzelnen Länder betreffen die auch kaum. Das heißt, es ist so, dass die Schiffe das einzelne Länder angefangen haben und gesagt haben, allein das Stück Land oder das Stück See, wo die durchfahren, um ihren Kram abzuliefern bei uns. Allein was die da für Verschmutzung machen, das betrifft uns schon so stark, dass wir da was tun müssen, haben die USA zum Beispiel gesagt. Und arbeiten gerade an einem gesetz, oder ich weiß nicht, ob es schon durch ist, wo es dann hieß, naja, dann wird halt auf Hoher See umgeladen. Das heißt, da kommt dann so ein kleines Frachtschiff und man fährt quasi von dem in internationalen Wässern bleibenden Stinker die Container zum Land. Also unglaublich, nur um diese Schadstoffe fernzuerhalten.
Also diese Diskussion, weil da gab es ja verschiedene Optionen. Economist war ein interessanter Artikel, wo es unter anderem darum ging, den Ärmelkanal und die Ostsee und so, also die Zulieferung zu Europa, Schadstoffärmer zu kriegen. Und da war es so, dass sie da Optionen diskutiert haben. Eine war, dass sie in die Schiffe einen zusätzlichen Tank einbauen, wo sie richtigen diesel reinmachen, also weniger Dreck und das Zeug, wo sie dann die letzten paar Kilometer mitfahren können. Die zweite Option war, da einen Filter, also Filter einzubauen. Nur sind so eine Filter, kosten halt im Betrieb auch Energie und müssen gewartet werden und gereinigt werden und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und deswegen wurde dann vermutet, dass die Schiffe dann halt genau an der 50-Meilen-Zone, was auch immer sie da im Filter installieren ist, dann wird dann halt der Filter eingeschaltet und sobald es wieder raus ist, wird der Filter wieder ausgeschaltet. Würde vermutlich schon dazu führen, dass zumindest in der Nähe des landes die Belastung sinkt, aber sicherlich nicht zu...
Wir haben es hier halt mit einem gemeinsamen Ökosystem zu tun. Da kann man sich überlegen, wie hilfreich unsere energiesparer und Umweltschutzaktionen hier auf dem Land sein können, überhaupt nur, wenn wir auf Hohe See sowas dulden.
Die spannende Frage ist ja dann auch, was passiert denn wirklich, wenn das Öl knapper wird? Also wenn man sich mal so, das ist ja nicht nur Öl, sondern auch Erdgas. Wenn man sich so anguckt, wo es überall drinsteckt, das war, wie gesagt, unser Booktipp, das wird das aus sehr schönen Erläutern, dem Last-All-Shock, sehr empfehlenswertes Buch, sollte man dringend mal lesen. Die Landwirtschaft beruht auch zu 90 Prozent auf Erdöl und Erdgas. Das heißt also, der Dünger wird aus Erdgas gemacht. Also alles, was wir heutzutage in unsere Felder rein düngen, 95 Prozent davon wird direkt aus Erdgas hergestellt. Und alles, was wir an landwirtschaftlichen Maschinen haben, wird mit Erdöl, also diesel, befüllt.
Und auch der Transport der Ware ist natürlich...
Und der Transport der Ware. Es gab ja dieses drastische Beispiel Nordkorea. Wie stark bei denen die Ernte eingebrochen ist, nachdem sie kein billiges russisches Erdöl mehr bekommen haben.
Kuba genauso.
Kuba war genau so ein Problem.
Also Kuba ist fast gestorben daran, weil sie natürlich auch noch ein Embargo gegen sich haben. Und Probleme hat, ein Öl von woanders zu importieren, weil die USA haben ja die Vorstellung, quasi wenn sie ein Embargo gegen Kuba machen, dann darf auch sonst kein Land mit Kuba handeln. Und haben dann quasi gedroht, wenn eine deutsche Firma mit Kuba handelt, dass dann andere deutsche Firmen oder von der deutschen Firma in Amerika, die könnten gepfändet werden und so eine Sache.
diese nationale Siblerhaft, ja.
Kuba hat ein echtes Problem gehabt deswegen. Und die haben ihre Landwirtschaft revolutioniert, als sie einfach mussten. Da habe ich hier auch einen Link, den ich in die Linkliste tun werde. Da gibt es eine schöne Dokumentation. So da sieht man eben, wie die angefangen haben, sich zu überlegen, wie man mit weniger Dünger klarkommt. Oder am besten ganz ohne Dünger. Und haben die Produktion von den Nahrungsmitteln auch näher an die Bevölkerung gekarrt. Und haben sich da so Kollektivsachen überlegt. Und die haben es geschafft von, ich glaube, die Metrik war irgendwie pro Kilo Nahrung, wie viel Liter Öl du brauchst. Und sie hatten am Anfang irgendwie 20 Liter Öl pro Kilo Nahrung. Und danach waren sie ein Kilo Nahrung zu irgendwie ein Zehntel Liter Öl. Also sie haben echt aus Not ihr System revolutioniert und exportieren das inzwischen auch. Ihre Ideen, wie man, also die haben nicht nur ein Feld zum Beispiel, sondern die haben so eine Art Sägezahn-Racks, damit um die Sonneneinstrahlung zu maximieren. Und also die haben sich da ganz clevere Sachen ausgedacht. Und ich denke mal, von da werden wir noch viel lernen können, wenn uns das auch betrifft mit den Ölknapphaltungen.
Und wie sind die, haben sich die absoluten Mengen entwickelt? Also sind die noch in der Lage, mit den Flächen die Bevölkerung zu ernähren?
Ja, gerade so.
Also aber das heißt aber, die Erträge pro Hektar sind auf jeden Fall eingebrochen?
Ja, tierisch natürlich. Also ich meine, ohne Dünger hast du erstmal ein generelles Problem. Das sind ja auch nicht nur Dünger, das sind auch so pestizide, die besteht aus Kohlenwasserstoffen und wird aus Öl hergestellt. Und da gibt es viele Probleme, aber ich meine, die Botschaft ist, dass Kuba es schafft, sich selbst zu ernähren, auch wenn sie praktisch kein Öl haben, was sie da verbrauchen können. Das heißt, es geht. Das ist schon mal ein Silberstrahl, der Hoffnung.
Na gut, der Punkt für uns, also für Deutschland, wäre ja nicht, dass es kein Öl mehr gibt oder kein Erdgas mehr gibt, sondern dass es nur sehr teuer wird. Das heißt also, die Incentivierung, den Einsatz zu senken, ist auf jeden Fall da, aber bedeutet halt am Ende, dass die Leute, die nicht damit leben können, dass ihre Nahrung teuer wird, für die wird es halt echt hart.
Na ja, immerhin können wir von Kuba lernen, dass es überhaupt geht, dass man sich selbst ernähren kann.
zumindest in dieser Klimazonung.
Genau, das stimmt natürlich. Na gut, inwieweit das übertragbar ist auf unseren Landbau, das werden wir dann sehen.
Aber der interessante Punkt ist natürlich vor diesem Hintergrund, dass jetzt die Zockerei mit landwirtschaftlichen Produkten losgeht. Also wäre eine spannende Frage, ob es da einen Zusammenhang zur absehbaren Erdwirknappheit gibt.
Das ist nicht klar. Also es gibt gerade einige Sachen, wo das Zocken losgeht. Wir haben ja mal zwei rausgesucht. Die erste war, dass ein mysteriöser Spekulant den gesamten Kakaomarkt Europas leergekauft hat, an einem Tag. Und zwar war das am 17. Juli die Meldung. Der hat einfach allen verfügbaren Kakao gekauft. Und die Märkte sind normalerweise schon in der Lage...
Der interessante Punkt war, was der offensichtlich tut, ist, eine klassische Market Cornering zu fahren.
Spekulation natürlich, ne?
Er besteht halt nicht... Also normalerweise ist es so, wenn du futures auf Kakao kaufst, dann verkaufst du die am Anfang. Und was der aber tut, ist, der besteht auf physischer Lieferung.
Das erinnert so ein bisschen an Porsche und VW, ne?
Ja, der will den Kakao haben. Und das ist halt genau der klassische... Also wie im alten Chicago, da machen wir einen Buchtipp in einer späteren Sendung, da gibt es ein großartiges Buch dazu, wie sich halt diese ganzen Spekulationsmethoden in Chicago entwickelt haben, mit den landwirtschaftlichen...
Mit den Mobstern?
Ne, mit den Landwirtschaftsprodukten, wie sich da diese futures entwickelt haben. Und eine klassische Methode, da Geld zu verdienen, in kurzer Zeit ist so ein Market Cornering. Es besteht darin, dass du halt unter der Hand möglichst viele futures kaufst auf einen Stichtag und dann auf physischer Lieferung bestehst. Und da alle anderen sich aber auch nur mit Papier eindecken können, können sie am Ende nicht liefern und müssen irgendwo her zu Mondpreisen Kakao kaufen oder was auch immer gerade die Market Corner ist.
Also man sollte vielleicht erklären, normalerweise der absolute Großteil des marktes eigentlich alles ist Spekulation. Ist reine Spekulation. Da sieht nie jemand überhaupt irgendwelchen physischen Kakao. Und diese ganzen Optionstradereien, die basieren auch auf der Annahme, dass die meisten nie eingelöst werden. Und das ist nur so ein restrisiko quasi, dass jemand tatsächlich von dir fordern könnte, dass du das einlöst.
Und es gibt zum Beispiel eine Chicago-Warn-Terminenbörse, gibt es für den physischen Markt mittlerweile eine separate Marktabteilung, die ist nur 10 Prozent so groß wie die Zockerabteilung. Und jetzt hinzugehen zu sagen, ich will dann am Ende sehen, so?
Das bringt viele Leute echt in die Bredouille. Und das war das Ding mit Volkswagen und Porsche, natürlich.
Da hast du die Aktien denn haben wollen.
Genau, da hat Porsche die ganzen Optionsscheine gekauft und hat mehr gekauft, als es dir eigentlich eine Aktien gibt oder fast alle. Und dann kam halt raus, von VW sind überhaupt nur so und so viel Prozent nicht im staatsbesitz. Und dann haben die plötzlich alle gemerkt, die Banken, die die Optionen verkauft hatten, dass sie tatsächlich liefern müssen, dass jemand das haben will und das sie liefern müssen. Und dann gab es diese gar nicht. Daher ist plötzlich der Aktienpreis in zehnfache.
Ja, auf tausend Euro oder so.
Ja, ja, völlig unglaublich.
diese Zockereien gingen natürlich weiter. In Russland ist ein Großteil der Weizenernte ausgefallen.
Weil es zu heiß war.
Die haben wegen den Bränden Weizen Exportverbot erlassen. Und das steht tatsächlich auch noch häufiger zu erwarten in Zukunft, dass Nahrungsmittel-Exporte eingeschränkt werden. Aus dem einfachen Grund, weil die Regierung weiß, dass wenn die Leute hungern, dann ist das nicht gut für uns. Also aus vergangenen Revolutionen und ähnlichen Dingen weiß man, dass wenn vier Tage kein Brot in den Läden liegt, dann stürzt die Regierung.
Das hat ja auch Gorbatschow wohl gesehen. Und deswegen ging das überhaupt los mit den ganzen Reformen. Also man muss vielleicht dazu sagen, dass Russland in den Top 3 der Weizen Exporteure der Welt ist. Das heißt, Russland eher unten, jetzt halt nicht mehr. Aber wenn Russland dann sagt, wir haben dies Jahr keinen Weizen, dann machen sich einige Leute am Markt natürlich Sorgen.
Und dementsprechend entwickeln sich da gerade die Preise.
Ich hab neulich mit so einem Farmer geredet, der mich da durch die Gegend gefahren hat und der hat mir erzählt, dass die Bauern in England haben, also machen unsere Bauern auch, dass im Vorjahr legt man sich auf den Preis fest für seinen Weizen. Und er meinte, der Preis, den die da gemacht haben, die obere Schale, also den guten Weizen, da legt man sich im Vorjahr drauf fest mit Preis. Und der Preis davon liegt jetzt unter dem, was die für ihren Scheißweizen, der nur in die viehvermessung geht, auf dem Sportmarkt kriegen. Also da kann man schon echt ins Klo greifen mit diesen Spekulationen.
Tja, das ist eine krasse Nummer. Also diese Weizen-Spekulationen. Also bisher war es ja eigentlich immer so, dass die Pharma gesagt haben, okay, wir legen uns rechtzeitig auf den Preis fest, damit wir wissen, was wir kriegen sollen.
Das kann auch in die andere Richtung, also vor allem zu deinen Gunsten ausgehen natürlich. Und dass es so krass ist, wie es jetzt gerade läuft, also die Differenz waren irgendwie so 20, 30 Prozent. Das ist schon krass natürlich. Das habe ich auch noch nie erlebt. Aber letztendlich, weißt du, wenn du das im Vorjahr dich auf den Preis festlegst, dann hast du auch investitionssicherheit und weißt das so.
Wahrscheinlich ist es besser zu wissen, was du bekommst, als sich denn darüber zu ärgern.
Wenn du Leidenschaften bekommst, verlosst du was.
Na vielleicht, wenn du clever warst, hast du noch irgendwie 20 Prozent zurückgehalten und nicht verkauft oder so.
Ja, das hängt halt auch von der Ernte ab.
Ja, stimmt. Du musst ja wissen, was du ja leisten kannst. Also meine, mit den Russen ist ja ohnehin so eine interessante geschichte. Also wir haben ja gerade schon mehrfach erwähnt, dass sich Deutschland ja gerade auf einem expliziten Kuschelkurs Richtung Russland befindet. Und der Hintergrund dafür ist natürlich, dass sich Deutschlands Energie im wesentlichen auf russischen Erdöl stützt, so zu 30 Prozent etwa. Wir sind da halt schon in einer Abhängigkeit, die nun natürlich auch politische Folgen zeigt. Also jetzt hatten wir schon mal erwähnt, die zu erwartenden neuen Einreiserregelungen und visumsbestimmungen. Die geschichte jetzt mit der Schröder Pipeline Nord Stream und der Joschka-Pipeline, die dann dazu dienen soll, die Abhängigkeit von den Russen zu senken, sind nun ja doch die großen...
Nee, nee, nee, Moment.
Da?
Eigentlich ist da Russland beteiligt an der Pipeline.
Ist das so?
Ja, und da geht es unter anderem darum, dass wir gesagt haben, alternativ könnten wir doch Öl über die Türkei aus Afrika kaufen. Und deswegen haben wir da jetzt eine Pipeline hin. Die Russen sind ja nicht blöd, die sind an allem beteiligt. Also am Ende verdienen die vielleicht dann im Erdgas nichts, aber an der Pipeline.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Russland ist natürlich ein sehr fasziniertes Thema. Putin hat in den letzten Wochen ja wieder einige seiner spektakulären Stunts abgeliefert mit den geschichten und der positioniert sich ja offensichtlich als nächster Präsident. Darum, die Frage ist halt, ob er eine Rokade macht mit WDF oder ob es da wieder noch völlig andere Überraschungen gibt. Cool fand ich ja diesen Spruch, den er da gebracht hat. Da saß bei irgendwelchen Babuschkasten auf einem Dorf und hat sich mit denen unterhalten und dann wurde er gefragt, ob er jetzt wieder der nächste Präsident wird. Da habe ich gesagt, na ja, man kann natürlich sein Leben damit verbringen, am Ufer des flusses zu sitzen und das Wasser vorbeifließen zu sehen, oder man kann das Heft des Handelns in die Hand nehmen und was tun. Sie kennen mich ja und sie wissen, was ich damit tun werde. Die spannende Frage ist, ob er tatsächlich in der Lage ist, mit WIDAF abzuservieren. Die momentane Machtkonstellation in Russland sieht so aus, dass es drei große Säulen gibt. Es gibt zum einen das Militär, zum anderen gibt es die Geheimdienstfraktionen, also nicht nur, sondern auch die Leute, die aus dem Ex-KGB kamen und zu diesen Strukturen gehören und die Wirtschaftsunternehmen gegründet haben, die dazugehören und so. Die sind unter einem stückvertretenden Ministerpräsidenten eingeordnet da. Dann gibt es die mit WIDAF-Gruppe, das sind die sogenannten Civilliki. Das sind so vorwiegend aus St. Petersburg stammende ex-Oligarchen und so Leute, die einfach da Wirtschaft machen wollen, die noch relativ demokratisch gesinnt sind. Wenn man sich anguckt, was der mit WIDAF so twittert, der ist ja durchaus zumindest bemüht, irgendwie das Image eines demokratischen rechtsstaates so ein bisschen zu vermitteln. Der, der twittert, ist durchaus lustig. Und die Frage ist jetzt halt, wenn er mit WIDAF absolviert werden würde, würde das heißen, dass genau diese doch recht starke Machtgruppe nicht mehr vertreten ist.
Also es gab ja schon eine Ansage, dass sie ein Gentleman Agreement machen und dass nur einer zur Wahl antritt.
Was denn heißt das da? Also wahrscheinlich noch Harde-Bauen, ja.
Vermutlich.
Also wäre wahrscheinlich das Schlauste so.
Also der mit WIDAF ist ja auch ganz gut angekommen eigentlich.
Ja erstaunlicherweise. Am Anfang dachte er ja so eine...
Am Anfang dachte er aber, das ist für eine Mayonnette, aber eigentlich ist das ganz gut.
Macht er doch irgendwie seinen Job da offensichtlich ganz gut, ja. Da gab es auch diese geschichte jetzt mit den Domains von Putin, ne?
Genau, also es gab so eine Organisation, die unter anderem gov.ru betreibt, kümmert sich da offenbar um die Wahlkampfdomains auch. Und die haben sich jetzt eben Putin 2012 geholt, aber eben nicht mit WIDAF 2012.
Ja, verstehe.
Und da hieß es dann, das heißt doch bestimmt was. Und dann alle so, nein, nein, legt euch da mal nichts bei.
Früher gab es doch auch diesen Job, der Kreml-Astrologen, der dann halt da irgendwie angeguckt hat, auf welchen Parteifotos wer in der ersten, zweiten und dritten Reise steht und irgendwie daraus gedeutet haben, wer jetzt irgendwie dann wieder in der Konstellation da irgendwie auf oder abgestiegen ist oder in Ungnade gefallen ist. Und irgendwann haben sie dann gemerkt, dass da Leute rausgefotoshopt wurden, also nicht gefotoshopt, sondern per Hand herausretuschiert worden und haben dann daraus irgendwie gedeutet, wer jetzt irgendwie den nächsten Unfall hat.
Es gab ja gerade so einen großen Photoshop-Fall in Ägypten.
Wobei es umstritten ist, dass es ein Photoshop-Fall ist, weil es nicht dieselbe Foto gewesen ist. Es ging darum, dass der ägyptische Präsident Mubarak auf einer Staatsmännerversammlung auf einem Foto so ganz am Rande irgendwo so mitschleichend und auf dem nächsten Foto bzw. auf dem gefotoshoppten Foto dynamisch voranschreiten vor Obama und wer da sonst noch so da war, den Führer mint. Offensichtlich haben sie dann halt genau dieses Foto, diese veränderte Fotoversion publiziert mit dem Mubarak, der dann da voranschreitet.
Und da hieß es dann, Photoshop, Haupt-Photoshop. Also das sieht schon auch echt gefotoshoppt aus. Die Kunst der... I can see the pixels.
Ja, I can see the pixels. Also die Kunst der politischen Fotomontage ist auf jeden Fall nicht tot, sondern hat eine große Zukunft. Da können wir davon ausgehen.
Zu Putin gab es noch eine andere lustige Meldung vor ein paar Tagen. Da hieß es nämlich, er hat sich mit Berlusconi getroffen. Und Berlusconi, der ist ja nun auch schon ein älterer Jahrgang, 75 oder so, und der hat dann rumgewitzelt, ja ja, die medizinische Forschung, und wir werden ja alle stein alt werden, und er will ja arbeiten, bis er 120 ist, und Putin bestimmt auch, und Putin hat ihn dann wohl so angegrinst und meinte, 120? Ja, na ja, und dann wären wir beide noch im Amt sein, so. Der Plan ist klar, ich denke, das war die Tätigkeits-Idee.
Ja, na ja, so der lupenreine Demokratin, die sagt, wir irgendwie unangemeldet demonstrieren, geht der verdient nichts anderes als den Knüppel auf den Kopf. Der wird uns also vor einer Weile halten bleiben.
Ist auch gut so. Könnte alles deutlich schlimmer laufen, natürlich. Also ich weiß noch, als, wie hieß der, Boris Yeltsin abtritt und alle gedacht haben, oh Gott, wir sind alle verloren, weil ich meine, damals haben wir uns ja noch Sorgen gemacht, so wer hat denn da jetzt eigentlich den Finger auf den Atom?
Oder hat überhaupt noch jemand den Knopf? Also weiß noch jemand, wo der Knopf ist.
Aber ich meine, also da, dass dieser Yeltsin überhaupt ins Amt kommen konnte, der war ja irgendwie dauerbetrunken.
Naja, der hatte damals als die, eine Stahlleber, als der Putsch war, war er noch halbwegs fit und also da war er noch Moskauer Bürgermeister und hat er diesen Putsch im wesentlichen mit Niederschlag geöffnet und hat ihn dann ja ins Amt gebracht, so und aber...
Also das war schon die Aussichten, die es damals gab, da war Putin noch Gold, ja, also das hätte auch viel schlimmer laufen können.
Ja, und auf jeden Fall sieht man, dass er Spaß an seinem Job hat, ne?
Eine Sache noch, es gibt ja traditionell immer so diese Dreierkonstellation, früher war das halt nicht die Zivilis, sondern die Partei und da haben sich immer zwei zusammengetan gegen den anderen. Und insofern wäre jetzt natürlich wieder die Frage, wenn das immer noch so läuft, auf wessen Seite steht denn das Militär?
Na Putin hat sich ja immer davon, Putin hat es ja so so eingerichtet, dass er auf diesen drei Säulen balanciert, sozusagen.
Also der mag auch das Militär gern, meinst du?
Na klar, also der muss halt immer alle diese drei Säulen in der Balance halten, dass keine von denen sich mit den anderen verbündet. Also es gibt ja diese Theorie, dass die am Ende der Absturz des Imperiums ja dadurch kam, dass der KGB angefangen hat, die Partei und das Militär zu unterwandern. Und dann halt dadurch die Machtbalance außer Kontrolle geriet. Und das wiederum aber dazu führte, dass am Ende dessen, also nach dem Fall der Sowjetunion, eben die KGB-Jungs diejenigen waren, die dann sozusagen das Imperium wieder zusammengekratzt und Putin in die Hand gedrückt haben.
Nee, ist ja auch, kommt ja aus der Richtung.
Kommt wohl aus der Richtung, ja. Aber ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall, also Kreml-Astrologie wird sicherlich wieder ein spannendes Hobby, so werden wir sie sicherlich auch noch ein bisschen betreiben. Naja, also auch zum Thema Astrologie, wir hatten ja letztes Mal über U-Boot-Kommunikation geredet und da gab es diesen lustigen Sender UVB76 und da hattest du im Blog irgendwelche Bilder, von denen behauptet wurde, wie war die geschichte?
Also erstmal, das ist ein Nummernsender aus Russland und den gibt es seit, weiß ich nicht, den 70s oder so, der ist echt lange in Betrieb und der hat eigentlich größtenteils, also der hat über seine Laufzeit, hat ja so drei, vier, fünf Botschaften abgesetzt und ansonsten hat er so ein Signal gehabt. Und dafür ist er auch bekannt gewesen eigentlich, dass er eben den Hobby-Funkern immer ihre Frequenzen gestört hat. Und dann war der plötzlich aus, so vor ein paar Wochen ging es, und dann war der plötzlich aus. Und dann gab es weltweit Panik so nach dem Motto, oh mein Gott, vielleicht irgendwie hat er jetzt seine alle Atomraketen abschießen Signal gesendet, du musst jetzt nicht mehr gebraucht. Das war die erste richtige Verschwörungsmensch.
Die Theorie war doch, dass es ein Declan-Switch ist, dass irgendwas losgeht, wenn dieses Signal nicht mehr da ist.
Ja, oder so rum, also kommt aufs gleiche heraus, jedenfalls, wir sind alle tot, was sich dann nicht bewahrsagt hat. Und plötzlich sendete der wieder, und das war wieder so eine Nummern-Botschaft, wo sie sich alle die Zähne dann ausbeißen, die zu entschlüsseln. Und dann gab es plötzlich Fotos auf Englisch-Russia, glaube ich, das ist so eine Domain-Fotoblock. Und die haben, die haben eigentlich, also das kann ich auch nur jedem empfehlen, sich da mal durchzuklicken, die haben zum Beispiel immer so Fotos gehabt von den atombetriebenen Leuchttürmen. Also das sind, teilweise haben die richtig krasse Bilder. Und da haben sie halt Bilder von diesem UVB-76 vorgegeben.
Was aber der totale Fake war?
Naja, das waren so generische Bunkerbilder.
Ich hab mir die genauer angeguckt und kann durchaus sein, dass die aus dem Bunker von diesem Ding kommen. Aber so wie die aussehen, kann dieser Sender nicht mehr irgendwie, also vor 15 Jahren oder so sind diese Bunker da abgesoffen. Und die sahen eher aus wie so ein normaler Standard-Kommandoposten-Bunker mit irgendwie Schalthafeln für die Elektrik und die Luftumwelt und so. Also da war nicht zu sehen auf diesen Bildern, was irgendwie auf einen großen Sender hinwies. Also jedenfalls nicht die Dimensionen, die dieser Nummer in den Sender haben sollte. Und dann gab es noch eine Freaksendung, ne?
Genau, das war quasi der Nord am Rande. Da gab es dann plötzlich eine Sendung auf der Frequenz, wo dann ein, zwei Leute gegrüßt wurden aus der Community, die diesen Sender sonst hören. Der Leute, die diesen Sender beobachten und die die Sachen dann auf YouTube stellen. Und da hat sich natürlich schnell als Fake herausgestellt, als sie eigentlich mal einen Spaß erlaubt. Aber das finde ich schon eigentlich einen schönen Gruß.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das war lustig. Tja, naja, die Russen und ihr Militär sind natürlich auch noch wieder jetzt in einem anderen Kontext interessant. Und zwar die Amis versuchen ja gerade aus Afghanistan abzuziehen. Und jetzt stellt sich heraus, dass was sie gerade hinderigend versuchen ist, sich die geschichte so hinzubiegen, also den Narrative, die Legende zu diesem Krieg so hinzubiegen, dass sie da psychologisch einigermaßen heil rauskommen.
Nein, nein, das war kein Vietnam.
Genau, das war kein Vietnam und es war notwendig, dass wir da sind. Und wir haben da wirklich was erreicht. Was ich angesichts der Situation, die auf Afghanistan berichtet wurde, eine einigermaßen sportliche Angelegenheit finde. Aber interessant ist, da gibt es jetzt wohl gerade so Dutzende Thinktanks, die genau das versuchen, diese geschichte zu designen für Obama. Und die haben dann auch Leute nach Russland geschickt, um mit den alten Generälen zu reden, die damals den Abzug gemanagt haben.
Wie die das intern verkauft haben.
Wie die das intern verkauft haben und vor allen Dingen, wie sie die Verhandlungen mit den damaligen Mujahidin und Taliban organisiert haben, um diesen Abzug auf die Reihe zu kriegen. Also man sieht schon, die müssen da so einigermaßen verzweifelt sein. Aber das ist eigentlich auch nicht wirklich verwunderlich, wenn man sich so anguckt, was die da für Leute in die Regierung gehievt haben. Wie war das mit dem Präsident?
Genau, Karzai, das ist eine einzige Lachnummer, was es da immer gibt. Es ging irgendwie damit los, dass es hieß, sein Sohn ist ein Warlord oder zumindest mit Warlords zusammen am Drogenexport beteiligt. Das war eine der ersten Meldungen, die ist aus der Reihe Karzai. Und jetzt vor kurzem gab es eine andere Meldung. Und wenn man mal auf Wikipedia zu Karzai nachguckt, dann findet man raus, der hat eine größere Familie, von denen aber so ein relativ großer Teil in Amerika restaurants betreibt.
In der Gegend von Washington.
Ja, in Washington auch, in Chicago, also nicht nur Washington. Aber die Theorie dahinter, das kann ich mir richtig lebhaft vorstellen.
Ey, wir brauchen mal einen Präsidenten!
Wir brauchen mal jemanden, der auf Afghanistan...
Kennt jemanden in Afghanistan? Ich war gestern nach Lecker Essen, also lass mal fragen. Vielleicht kennt ihr jemanden, der...
Genau, ich kenne jemanden, der...
Ja klar, mein Bruder.
Der kann gut kochen.
Nein, mein Bruder, der kann nicht so gut kochen, der kann Präsidenten sein.
Mein Bruder, der kann das.
Das wäre, auf jeden Fall kriegst du wieder plausible Theorie.
Also Kazaai hat sechs Brüder, da ist noch einiges anderes zu holen.
Wäre es auf jeden Fall, hier liegt eine valide Theorie. Ja, also jedenfalls diese geschichte mit dieser Kriegslegende erwartet uns noch so einiges. Zumal jetzt gerade...
Ich versuche mir immer die Russen vorzustellen, wenn ich sowas lese, ja, weil es gab ja auch diese andere geschichte, dass die Amis in ihre Munitionen verballert haben und Nachschub brauchten und halt alle anderen Quellen waren versiegt und dann haben sie ernsthaft die Russen gefragt, ob sie nicht durch ihre Ränge Munition importieren können. Und die Russen haben erst gedacht, das ist ein Witz. Also die zuständigen Russen, die müssen da auch echt irgendwie wahrscheinlich sitzen, die machen da ein Trinkspiel draus, weißt du, so Shotgläser auf dem Tisch, zumal sehen, dass die Amis als nächstes wollen. So und ich meine, das muss doch der definierende Tag deiner Karriere sein, wenn die Amis anrufen und wissen wollen, wie du eigentlich damals deinen Verlust, deine Bevölkerung verkauft hast.
Die Amis wollten zumal nicht besonders gut verkauft haben. Die Amis brauchten sie auch nicht so, oder? Na ja, das war schon hart. Die innerrussische Ansicht dazu war schon nicht sehr genädig und hat sicherlich auch zum Großteil der Diskreditierung des damaligen regimes beigetragen, dass sie halt da sinnlos 10.000 Leute in diesem Krieg verheizt haben und es keinerlei Erklärungen dafür gab, wofür es jetzt gut sein sollte, weil an diese Legende vom afghanischen Brudervolk, was halt irgendwie in den Mittelalter entrissen wurde, hat da halt auch niemand mehr geglaubt. Also das ist halt schon ziemlich, ziemlich ja Bullshit. Und die, was jetzt da gerade passiert ist, da gibt es jetzt gerade einen Bankrun, weil sie in, also die wichtigste Bank in Afghanistan, die in Afghanistan, über die auch die Gehälter der Polizisten und Lehrer und so abgewickelt werden.
Ist auch in den Händen von einem Grasei bitte?
Ist auch in den Händen von einem, von dieser Sippe da und hat offensichtlich da so einigermaßen wirtschaftliche Probleme, weil die Vergabe von Krediten da offensichtlich nicht nach den Grundlagen von Wirtschaftlichkeit oder irgendwie sowas passiert, sondern nach, ja, wo müssen wir denn nochmal ein bisschen jemanden glücklichstimmen, so. Also, das ist halt so ein, also, diese ganze Banking hat ja völlig andere Grundlagen. Und nun gibt es da wirklich erste Anzeichen von einem fetten Bankwahn, so. Also, wo die Leute hingehen und sagen, wir hätten jetzt...
Also, das war hart genug, dass die das Militär geholt haben.
Wir hätten jetzt gerne mal alle unser Geld.
Um die Leute da zu verprügeln, damit ihr nicht...
Und alle ihr Geld abholen, ne? Ja.
Also, der Karzai-Bruder mit dem Drogendeal, von dem gab es dann auch irgendwann eine CIA-Connection. Also, das ist eine großartige geschichte, weil das ausgerechnet den Typ... Da haben sie echt so alles, was es an organisierter Kriminalität gibt, da haben sie in der Familie echt vereint, oder? Ich meine, Banker, das ist ja schon schlimm genug, ja?
Drogen?
Drogenhandel, CIA-Connection und dann dieser korrupte Präsident, natürlich Politiker, auf Weier.
Also diese Familie, da kann man bestimmt noch mehrere Bücher drüber schreiben.
Da haben sie echt die richtigen zum Präsidenten gemacht.
Gut, damit werden wir, glaube ich, mal wieder durch für heute.
Genau, also wenn unser Aufnahme-Equipment kommt, versuchen wir noch eine Sendung zu machen diesen Monat nach dem, den wir das werden.
Ja, wir werden auf jeden Fall noch eine diesen Monat machen. Und dann hoffen wir mal, dass die Audi-Qualitätsprobleme dann über jeglichen Zweifel erhaben sein werden. Und bis dahin wünschen wir euch alles Gute, viel Spaß beim Nachklicken und ja, noch einen schönen Spätherbst oder so ähnlich.